you take your seats okay let me first of
all welcome and thank all of you for
being here and I would like to thank in
particular the many delegations that
this year are present at ministerial
level I take it as an encouraging sign
those from the region those from the
Astana group those from the neighboring
countries and I would like to in
particular recognize the foreign
ministers of Turkey and Jordan but all
and also that the foreign minister of
Lebanon is joining us and the presence
of members of the Security Council and
of many EU member states I think this
gives us a good good platform to try and
advance on our support to the political
process that we see it's needed in in
Syria I'd also like to welcome the
representatives of Syrian civil society
who have joined us today and that will
address us later to bring an important
perspective that for us is the most
important one the one of the Syrian
people because if we are here today as
to serve them and to try and achieve
peace in the country so that they can
live normal lives again the war in Syria
is not over yet
with these words I opened our meeting
exactly one year ago and sadly these
words are still true today
we all took a side of relief when
another Massacre was avoided in Eid Lib
after the deal between Turkey and Russia
and I would like to thank their
engagement in this respect yet the risk
of an offensive remains and I believe
the first objective we share today
to call on the astara guarantors were
present here to safeguard the last
remaining the escalation zone and beyond
Italy Syria is still not at peace the
conflict is evolving it's changing its
regional dimension is even stronger than
in the past and this worries us Syria is
divided millions of people are still
displaced inside the country and outside
of the country there is no winner in
this world there might be military
victories but there is no winner in this
world certainly not the people of Syria
were paying the highest price and let me
mention in particular the women of Syria
that have shown an incredible courage
determination and wisdom and nobody will
win
neither the war nor the peace without a
negotiated political solution and this
is why just after my opening remarks I
will be honored and pleased to pass the
floor to Staffan de Mistura a negotiated
political solution that opens the way
towards a United independent democratic
and inclusive Syria a negotiated
political solution can only emerge in
the United Nations framework and this is
why we're having this meeting here today
in this framework of the General
Assembly and I'm glad to see that a new
international consensus is emerging on
this very basic idea that has always
been at the center of the European Union
work on Syria and for Syria but only
together we can help put Stefan's work
back on track and make sure that the
constitutional committee can start
concentrating on substance in Geneva
starting the political process Stephan
has all our full support he knows that
this has always been the case this will
continue to be the case you can be sure
that our only goal our only agenda our
only objective as European Union is to
support the United Nations mediation and
to help start meaningful negotiations
towards a political solution
and with this goal in mind I am glad to
announce our intention to host a third
brasses conference on the future of
Syria and the region I would like to
invite you all to the third Brussels
conference on the last week of March
next year hoping that by then we will be
in condition to gather and mobilize
international and regional support to a
political process that by then hopefully
inshallah will be underway the Brussels
two conference last spring was crucial
to raise humanitarian support for the
Syrian people and this is something we
will address in the second part of our
meeting today I'm an Italian support for
the Syrian people but also for the host
communities and I'm proud to tell you
that we have already delivered on 95
percent of the pledges that were done in
Brussels last spring we have kept our
word to the Syrian people and to Syria's
neighbors and I think this consistency
is relevant for the credibility of the
work that lies ahead of us we've proven
this credibility to be there on the
humanitarian side I hope and I believe
we have the space for doing the same on
the political side of our work next year
expect our conference to be hopefully
depending on the work that will happen
or not on the UN auspices more focused
on the political support and the support
we can mobilize to accompany
negotiations but also expect the
conference to be a Syrian week providing
the stage for the best part of the
Syrian society because too often we
discuss of Syria but not with the
Syrians it will be a stage for Syrian
women for Syrian youth and for Syria
civil society that has survived through
this seven years of war saving lives and
the very possibility of life in Syria
they are Syria and the future of Syria
must be in their hands not ours
Syria today is still very far from being
the peaceful democratic and inclusive
country but all
Syrians can feel at home every Syrian
dreams to go back home every time we
talk with any of the men and women and
children that we meet outside of Syria
or inside Syria they tell us this and we
can only support this dream let me thank
once again the host communities
particularly in Lebanon Jordan and
Turkey but also in Egypt and Iraq and in
Europe our common goal is to create the
conditions for a safe and dignified
return of all Syrians to their land
still today most Syrians simply don't
have a home to go back to the properties
are being confiscated and many would
risk forced conscription or unlawful
arrests and I am glad we will hear more
from Graham day from the UNHCR because
we would trust their assessment and
their work and we would support their
assessment and their work on the
creation of the conditions for the
Syrian refugees to return home last but
not least we Europeans are willing to
contribute to the reconstruction but a
political solution must be under way
most Syrians don't want to go back to a
country where there is no accountability
and where political detainees are still
in jail the people of Syria ask for the
end of the war and for a negotiated
political solution and this would be we
believe the only realistic basis for a
sustainable peace because military
victory does not necessarily imply
winning the peace the people of Syria
want and need a negotiated political
solution and let me conclude on a
positive note
against all odds I believe a political
solution is still possible and we could
be very close to achieving it but only
if we all work to make it happen this is
the moment to pull all our weight in
support of the UN process of your work
stuffin so that we can finally see the
beginning of the end of the Syrian world
I thank you very much for your presence
for your attention and I would pass
immediately the floor to Staffan de
Mistura thank you thank you thank you
for the recap for organizing this
hosting this event and for the words you
just said this is a very timely meeting
and an important one at the moment the
UN and the EU have had an exemplary
cooperation since the very beginning of
my mandate and even before and I welcome
very much your intention to be
persistent and also have a new brussels
conference because we need to review
every year where we are but also to
launch new initiatives clearly syria is
very much on the agenda of both EU and
the UN and rightly so
so i will not discuss about many things
i would just focus on two priorities if
you allow me
the first one is civilians civilians
civilians Syrian civilians protection
humanitarian assistance access funding
we will hear it from mark LOCOG and from
you Filippo how much this is upfront and
should be our priority in that context
ed Lib Lib is a main priority and will
remain so for reasons that you're all
familiar the civilians of Italy have
raised their voices particularly women
actually a new race and I refer to them
because we saw them with their own eyes
and many of you in this room have raised
your own voices regarding the fate of
the civilians in Italy and these voices
have contributed to what has been a very
remarkable
MOU those voices have been heard and
should be heard even in the future the
recent Russian Turkish deal is welcomed
very much welcome think we were about
two weeks ago three weeks ago when we
were waiting to see the worst-case
scenario and we look forward therefore
to its implementation we hope that all
sides will continue to engage in good
faith
putting protection of civilians first
and looking to address the threat
of terrorism strictly in accordance with
international humanitarian law we must
also be vigilant for obvious reasons
because the constant danger of
international escalation we had those
winds coming up when the it leap crisis
appeared not to be solving inside
despite this risk let's not miss this
opportunity there is a chance for open
conflict to wind down is not over the
conflict still there but there is a
chance to help it and major players we
know are talking that brings me to our
second priority the political process or
the political solution today the
government has strengthened its position
against terrorism we know that so there
is no reason for it not them feeling
more at ease to actually engage in a
political process and all sides have
been receptive to a constitutional
process we also heard that on the
occasion of the MOU both the President
Putin and President Erdogan both said
this is a window of opportunity to be
used for accelerating the political
process logically that would mean that
real talks can begin and common ground
could start to be found now we have
identified out of 2254 which still
remains the main point a vehicle to
begin this process it is a UN
facilitated Syrian owned syrian-led
constitutional committee the government
and the opposition delegations have been
identified and accepted in a balanced
list of Syrian civil society experts
independent tribal leaders and women
have been put together by us the UN has
carefully and flexibly consulted on that
list and on the rules of procedure so in
theory we could be starting next week we
can and there is no reason not to do it
in October
imagine the signal dear friends it would
send if in the next months we could
start a Constitutional Commission which
had been announced
anyway already eight months ago during a
very important meeting that took place
in Sochi which the UN participated to
that could be a stepping stone to a new
social contract and to broader steps to
create a safer calmer more neutral
environment leading to you and
supervised presidential and
parliamentary elections as per
resolution 2254 this is not just a
mantra is a true possibility phonetic
and you're right and saying we should
not miss this opportunity it is
precisely now when we have stepped back
from the confrontation in Italy that we
should be saying let us put this real
political process in place and build
some confidence building around it
frankly dear friends the Syrian people
have the right to expect that especially
at this moment and there is no doubt at
all that if that process goes moving and
was generally delivering it would help
unlock many many other things that is
why everyone will look now to see if
this constitutional committee can move
in October not in Christmas not next
year in October that is why we are going
to push for that and to make it move let
us also not forget there is a need to
build some confidence will data nice now
finally start becoming released
we shall talked about it and we have
been talking about it for now many
manses let's see if it starts happening
we low number 10 and similar legislation
being deed suspended so that housing
land property is properly addressed
there is a solid discussion on this
between our team in Damascus and the
government of Syria but we would like to
see some conclusion on it and some real
results with refugees have the
confidence to
turn home because they see some sort of
genuine change taking place some
political vision taking place after all
this is not only a question of bricks
and mortar but confidence the political
process can provide that one if we put
it in action the police process must
ultimately and we all know it and we
will always say so help to restore
ultimately the syrian serenity unity
independence and territory integrity and
Syrians must lead their force but the
Syrians themselves are asking us to help
them to find a way out of this conflict
they need to be helped and encouraged by
all of you and frankly the UN needs your
help too that's why thank you for doing
this today help means help
it means friendly advice yes we are
getting it good ideas yes but at some
point it means generally supporting the
UN when it seeks on your behalf to move
the process ahead of the many many
months of extensive consultation so we
are in that period now and I trust I can
continue to reach out to each of you in
order to get this type of support in
this way I believe we can see a balanced
and credible constitutional committee up
and running it will take time but it
will be starting moving and create some
new dynamic in what otherwise a process
that is so far being very slow I said
that the beginning of last month that we
were getting close to a moment of truth
dear friends that's exactly what we are
saying the Italy deal gives us a moment
of hope but also a window of opportunity
not to be missed
Federica I really want to say once again
how much we have been feeling constantly
accompanied by you personally by your
team in York member countries in what is
a common goal
thank you thank you stuff and I take
this applause as a sign of encouragement
recognition but also as a commitment
from all of us to help you in in your
role I have the difficult task now to
remind us all that we should try to
stick to the three minutes and I'll pass
immediately in the four to the foreign
minister of Turkey my Bluto so go take
the floor thank you very much for the
update despite some progress
unfortunately the conflict in Syria
continues to be a major challenge in our
region and even beyond for almost eight
years we have been witnessing the direct
impact of the crisis in our common
security and stability as neighboring
countries turkey Jordan and Lebanon had
more than their fair share in
shouldering multi-dimensional
responsibilities as the largest refugee
hosting country turkey hosts around 3.5
million Syrians and we have spent almost
32 billion u.s. dollars we welcome the
EU three plus three billion euro
commitments within the framework of the
facility for refugees in Turkey and out
of two billion you know euros dispersed
but we are working together how to speed
up this process on both sides I think as
it is in the agreement deal with at v--
sign we should use this money for the
daily living expenses of the refugees
particularly for the healthcare services
and their colleagues today we are at
another critical juncture it lip the
termination
and continuing engagement with russia
and iran produce positive results and a
looming catastrophe has been prevented
in sochi we signed a memorandum to
stabilize the situation in Italy and we
agreed on the preservation of it lift
status as a de-escalation area thus we
save thousands of innocent lives and
preempted a potential influx of millions
of refugees towards our borders and even
Europe we are now working with the
Russians and Iranians on how to
implement the memorandum and this
afternoon we are going to have
trilateral ministerial with my brother
Zarif and Sergey Lavrov sustained
engagement of the international
community will be needed in ensuring
full compliance by the regime
the memorandum has opened a new window
of opportunity and we should benefit
from the relative calm and to speed up
the political track in this connection
the constitutional committee must be
established without further delay and
this requires a credible and balanced
structure this is what we are trying to
do in our consultation with un special
envoy Staffan de Mistura I think we
should all together as support his
efforts and he has been doing a good job
and on these issues of return of
refugees and reconstruction we also see
a correlation with progress in the
political process
however the correlation should be a
dynamic and simultaneous rather than
static and conditional in nature we need
to support the people who are
voluntarily returning the country
reconstruction of the country is
something else assisting the refugees
and IDPs going back to their home is
something as tar total different thank
you very much thank you very much
I've Lutz I now get the floor to the
Deputy Foreign Minister
of the Russian Federation Sergei
vershinin reminding you that you have
translation from Russian on channel 1 I
will then give the floor to the Minister
of Foreign Affairs of Iran Javad Zarif
thank you so much I will speak in
Russian and as you said we have this
translation thanks so much what I am a
dummy Gaspar de l'arche of Street Rocco
it not foolish in which he retreats
though he was now a type of precision
irregular when a series Coakley's am
teaching at Ole Miss as a stylist Sara's
Anushka snatch mariachi katrakas alia
stability Russia leonianas [ __ ]
obsidian Amy we do but the Sonia
president me receipt or session a stone
tabria Sochi in Miranda must a blizzard
septum of gives own a discolored seed
lip done as a crushing and a problem no
clip Linea usually cucina bioevolutiva
Magdalene earful marijuana Verona posits
a guitarist at the politics key now put
politics curricular Ania actually stuff
na producer in a very boisterous team s
Puccini a shitty it is a past nasty me
on a garden
module diode sway sway Adagio building
mr. opening in milano mabuse's pass
ostrich nature presents tomorrow it will
be a solid Aeschylus a predator a senior
in Kerala Romanesque a Latina Syria a
prejudice to escalation to the true
Cisco erosion epidemic metal stone such
as category honesty pollute chilli PADI
Escada Mosca crystal tree mutiny Austin
series capacity Jana
eBay's famous narodna agric of
destruction Rosanna salsa me system new
path lead new role magnet and appearance
tobacco Hedley Byrne eagerly Egret me
Prakash Ishiguro's Amanda Steele there
was media what we have a premie near the
mosque an immediate relation with
massacres by the mask use of chemical
weapons we have proof that fighters in
Europe in Italy
using pseudo humanitarian accomplices of
terrorists from the white helmets
continued to prepare a staged event to
simulate use of chemical weapons again
and again we're directing the attention
of the international community that it
is necessary to put an end to these
dangerous provocations jeopardizing the
promise of reaching a political and
diplomatic solution of Syrian crisis our
position remains consistent and
unchanged Syrian conflict as well as
other regional crises does not have a
military solution and can be settled
only through a negotiation political
process this crucial understanding was
reiterated during the third summit in
Astana on the 7th of September in Tehran
presidents of Russia Iran and Turkey
have expressed preparedness to continue
active cooperation in the interests of
promotion of political process led and
conducted by the Syrians themselves
according to the decisions of the
Congress for Syrian national dialogue in
Sochi and resolution of the UN Security
Council 2254 Troy the three grantor
States will continue joint efforts to
shape constitutional committee in Geneva
in consultations with the stefan de
Mistura UN Security UN Special
Representative to truly launch the
comprehensive political process so
needed by Syria Middle Eastern region
and the whole international community it
is apparent that s situation in Syria is
stabilizing the front stage is taken by
the pond by post-conflict rehabilitation
and protection of rights of refugees and
IDPs to return we have to ensure a safe
voluntary and decent process of
returning of Syrians to their homeland
in this regard support of the
international community that is
providing additional humanitarian
assistance ensuring rebuilding of social
economic infrastructure providing new
projects that would provide jobs for
those returning all that is of utmost
importance we cannot allow for the
long-awaited pivot of the country to
normal and regular life to become
hostage to artificially set politicized
conditions and policies it
hi time it was understood that
unilateral sanctions
Brune detriment dot not to the Syrian
government but to regular civilians this
is a vicious and dannan practice not
only in Syrian but in any other
situation Russia will continue to
actively provide assistance to Syria
both on political and humanitarian
tracts since September 2015 with our
help more than 30,000 houses and 5,000
educational and 150 medical facilities
were rebuilt and renovated 1935
humanitarian actions also took place
Russian military doctors provided
medical assistance to 93 thousand
Syrians Russian engineers and
minesweepers have conducted large-scale
demining actions in different parts of
Syria including world cultural heritage
sites in Palmyra Basra old city of
Damascus and Aleppo we are convinced
that today all responsible members of
the international community and the UN
member states are faced with in
complicated tasks to provide assistance
to Syrian Syrian nation to overcome
detrimental consequences of war
elimination of last hot spots of
terrorism returning to normal peaceful
life we expect that we will be thankful
to those considering this tasks
including everyone the European Union
thank you for these efforts and we
expect that such efforts will continue
thank you very much
thank you and I'll give the floor to the
foreign minister of Iran Javad Zarif
followed by France convening this
meeting in also thanks to Stepan de
Mistura for his comprehensive briefing -
to all of us since my colleagues from
Turkey and Russian Federation already
briefed you on the Istana process and
the achievements that we have had since
the summit in Tehran as well as the work
that we've done in order to make sure
that the catastrophe that could have
happened in adlib was averted I hope we
need to address
the important fundamental issues that
are at stake first those principles that
we heart we have all agreed upon the
principle of respect for serious
territorial integrity national unity and
national sovereignty these should be not
principles as we simply continue to
reiterate but principles that we agree
to implement in action and on the ground
and that is an important task that we
all need to take into consideration the
second is to combat terrorism and
extremism in Syria this is a threat to
all of us we just felt part of that
threat this Saturday in Tehran when a
group affiliated with these extremist
groups open fire on innocent civilians
we need to be careful about this all of
us have experienced it and we need to be
very meticulous in dealing with this the
area around ad lib is populated by
nostra fighters and we need to be clear
that Nora needs to be removed from the
territory without civilian casualties
and that remains to be the goal of the
three sponsors as well as I hope the the
three guarantors as well as I hope that
of the international community
number two the political process must
start and must come to fruition we said
from the very beginning you all remember
that this conflict does not have a
military solution this conflict only has
a political solution we all need to
accept that but we all need to also
accept the realities on the ground the
political process cannot reverse the
realities on the ground the political
process needs to bring inclusion and
everybody needs to be included in the
political process and we are determined
to help Stefan as he proceeds with the
constitutional framework in order to
make sure that that political process
leads to a comprehensive solution in
Syria number three
reconstruction and return of refugees is
an important requirement now
it cannot wait for an eventuality that
may be far too ahead of us we need to
start now reconstruction as I think I
mentioned here last year should be a
dividend for peace not a dividend for
victory peace dividends help Syrians
come to end the war victory dividends
help continue the war I believe it is
important for all of us to start helping
Syrians as they go back to their homes
voluntary repatriation of Syrians to
their original homes not to resettlement
areas is an important requirement that
we all need to start helping right now
as it is taking place following
liberation of certain areas from from
terrorist occupation so these are
important elements that we need to keep
in touch in in mind we in Iran as well
as in our role within the astana process
will continue to help in whatever way we
can
and again I thank you very much for
convening this meeting general secretary
target Frances Giambattista Benoit a
Romney you thank you very much
thank you very much Jeff Eureka for this
meeting mr. special envoy the first
priority of France in this conflict is
to protect the civil population and we
take note of the agreement at the
memorandum about Italy and we will
continue to support turkey effort in
order to find negotiated solutions for a
Lib yes there are alternative to
escalation they exist second to answer
the humanitarian emergency Brussels to
was an important moment of mobilization
and we welcome the conference Bruce l3
next March and France will be committed
of course
third the other priority for France in
Syria is the fight against terrorism we
know what it is inside for example and
we know what it can implies but we know
also that it can't justify any massacres
that the regime can prepare so in the
Northeast we think that we must work to
stabilize the territories freed from -
to avoid any comeback of the terrorist
organization so in this context the
comeback of refugees must be on a
voluntary basis with dignity and
security conditions and we know how how
is the burden for neighboring countries
such as Lebanon Jordan Turkey Iraq or
Egypt and generosity honor them but now
we must be sure that refugees can be
back with the fall of the Wrights their
own rights and the refugees can come
back only with the political transition
and so the emergency is political of
course and we we are very glad to salute
the efforts of Stefan de Mistura in
order to launch the constitutional
committee as he said it is the work for
now not for tomorrow or next year so
France commitment will be will be very
high alongside the European Union the
small group in order to have a political
solution in Syria thank you very much
thank you I now give the floor to the UK
Alister Burt and then to the United
States thank you hi representative and I
welcome the chance for us all to meet
today thank you for your continuing
commitment to convening us so we can all
stand together in continued support to
the Syrian people and calling for an end
to this horrific conflict after nearly
eight years of fighting and suffering
firstly today I want to talk about Eid
Lib the ant Kingdom welcomes the
encouraging news that Turkey and Russia
have reached an agreement on the
northwest and the Russian commitment
that the planned regime offensive will
now not take place I've been clear over
recent weeks that the United Kingdom
considers a human catastrophe in the
region to be avoidable and I truly hope
that with this agreement we've
demonstrated that to be the case and if
this agreement is upheld that we have
averted massive human suffering perhaps
it's also that political opportunity
that something might open up and we know
how hard the special envoy is working
for this as his remarks today have made
very clear secondly I want to provide
reassurance to the Syrian people of the
United Kingdom's continued commitment to
working with the international community
to provide humanitarian relief for those
in greatest need our commitment to this
endeavor is unwavering but it needs
constantly said it's easy for the eyes
of the world to move on in order to
ensure we can continue to deliver on
this commitment however it is essential
that our partners be at the UN or NGOs
have safe and unsafe
had access to all areas of need so I
used this opportunity once again to call
on the regime and its backers to ensure
safe sustained and unimpeded
humanitarian access across all of Syria
finally I would like once again to thank
those countries who are so generously
hosting Syrian refugees who have fled
violence and persecution in their own
country particularly Jordan Lebanon and
Turkey your generosity is remarkable
it's truly recognized by the
international community and commended by
all
regrettably it's clear that the
conditions are not yet in place for
refugees to return to Syria voluntarily
with dignity in accordance with
international humanitarian law and to
respect the pressure that is placed on
host communities a political settlement
remains vital to achieving this we
remain clear that we will not consider
providing reconstruction assistance
without such a settlement while
recognizing the distinction between
stabilization and reconstruction we are
clear that without real change to
address the root causes of this terrible
conflict reconstruction efforts would be
rendered meaningless so the United
Kingdom will continue to use all
diplomatic tools in pursuit of an
inclusive political settlement and we
fully support and endorse once again the
efforts of our un special envoy Staffan
de Mistura thank you and I'll give the
floor to the United States Special
Representative for Syria ambassador
Jeffrey followed by Qatar it is an honor
to be here today we commend the EU in
its member states
I'm sure it is a honor to be here today
we come
it went straight yeah yeah excuse me
thank you madam chair it is an honor to
be here today we commend the EU in its
member states for organizing this event
and for their continued contributions to
the Syrian response the humanitarian
situation in Syria is hot breaking
furthermore the danger of escalation
remains real five major state forces are
in close proximity in Syria and any
misstep risks touching off broader
conflict those mistakes include the use
of chemical weapons by regime forces
however this is not only a moment of
risk but also a moment of opportunity a
potentially catastrophic offensive enid
Lib has as many of you have already
mentioned for the time being at least
been averted president Trump in the
General Assembly yesterday intentionally
used much of his speech to describe our
policy on Syrian detail first deescalate
the military conflict second use all the
diplomatic tools at our disposal to
reinvigorate the Geneva process in
advance a political solution that honors
the will of the Syrian people
that means help create a Syria that
meets minimum standards for
international recognition surrendering
its chemical weapons no longer posing a
threat to its neighbors severing its
ties with Iranian expansionism no longer
sponsoring terrorism in treating its
citizens humanely third adopt a strategy
to address Iran the brutal regime that
is fuelled and financed the Syrian
crisis in our view Iran and it's proxies
must leave Syria for there to be any
lasting peace as I said in the Security
Council last week Russia argues to the
world that the Syrian conflict is ending
in the situation is normalizing we
disagree we do not think that
recognition of the regime soliciting
reconstruction money and pushing Syria's
neighbors to send refugees home long
before it is safe to do so is good
policy
it essentially sweeps the past seven
years under the rug but the Syrian
conflict has not ended in a situation is
not normalized conditions are not yet
conductive for saved voluntary in'
dignified return of refugees in addition
the humanitarian needs of the Syrian
people and refugee hosting countries
remain immense within Syria aid is still
not reaching those who need it the
United States remains a single largest
donor for the Syrian response providing
more than eight point six billion in
humanitarian assistance since the start
of the crisis to the governments of
Turkey Jordan Lebanon Iraq and Egypt I
joined my colleague from the United
Kingdom in praising your generosity in
hosting millions seeking refuge from
this historic crisis it is inspiring and
the international community will
continue to support you a future Syria
will need reconstruction funding but the
Assad regime should get no help to
rebuild Syria until it is on a path of
genuine political reform in line with UN
Security Council resolution 2254 we must
thus speak with one voice not
normalizing the Syrian regime by helping
Assad rebuild a country until we see
irreversible steps forward on a
political process that leads to
constitutional reform UN supervised
elections with diaspora participation in
a political transition that reflects the
will of the Syrian people here one
important first step would be for the UN
Syrian envoy Staffan de Mistura to
convulsion emit e to quote our Turkish
colleague without further delay and
report back to the Security Council by
the end of October we need international
and European Union support for such a
position madam chair let me again thank
you and the European Union for hosting
this event thank you and all the floor
to the deputy prime minister of Qatar
followed by the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
Sheikh al thani of the floor thank you
thank you madam Arika mogherini the high
representative of the EU afore the
foreign political and security affairs
mr. stefano de Mistura US special envoy
to Syria ladies and gentlemen Hadi I
said I would like to express our
appreciation to the into the United
Nations and the European Union for
holding this meeting I would like to
thank their efforts with regard to the
Syrian crisis and their support for the
Syrian people as they experienced at
this painful tragedy ladies and
gentlemen the Syrian crisis for this
different dimensions and it's different
implications the current ones and the
future ones are on international peace
and security in the region and in the
world has given us pause and has caused
us much pain and shows the imbalance in
the international order with regards to
the crimes and the behavior of the
Syrian regime and its daily violations
against the rights of its people where
it kills and destroys and forcibly
displaces and changes the McCaffery
character of areas and uses
internationally banned weapons the
international efforts and political
efforts to resolve this crisis continue
to face obstacles due to the absence of
international Concord as well as the
narrow calculations of some and as and
this requires an international response
especially a response from the permanent
member states of the Security Council
they must shoulder their legal and moral
and ethical responsibilities and must
reconsider the strategy of dealing with
this crisis so that we can find a
peaceful resolution that would meet the
aspirations of the Syrian people without
any one-upmanship and here would like to
once again welcome the most recent Assoc
agreement that helped save many millions
of civilians from bloodshed in Idlib and
who are between the rock and a hard
place between the regime and the
terrorists and we confirm it that this
agreement must succeed by being
committed to all of its conditions that
would also like to support the political
process that is being sponsored by the
net additions in order to arrive at a
solution to the crisis we'd also like to
welcome all international regional
efforts sir that enhancer and are in
line with this process in accordance
with international miss resolutions
including Geneva 1 in 2012
constitutes an addition to Security
Council resolution 2254 these both
constitute the main pillars of to find a
fundamental solution to this crisis so
that the Syrian people would determine
their own fate while maintaining
territorial integrity and sovereignty
dependence for Syria under high material
level it is unfortunate to see the
continued suffering of the Syrian people
without doubt alleviating their
suffering requires that the
international community to honor its
humanitarian commitments and provide the
necessary aid and take the required
measures that would guarantee the
implementation of resolution 21:56 of
the Security Council which discusses the
facilitation of Hypatia in aid from any
party to all the harmed areas and
affected areas in Syria as well as
providing aid to see refugees in
neighboring and hosting countries and
offering the necessary financial aid to
them and here I'd like to note that
Qatar has fulfilled all of its past
pledges through its political
discussions and the pleasure conferences
the most recent of which was Brussels -
this year the state of Qatar has spared
no effort and continuing to offer all
forms of support and aid to our Syrian
brethren in coordination with our
international partners it is and
gentlemen with the continued grave
violations but that the Syrian regime
commits of the humanitarian order and as
is recorded by the knighted nations and
its reports the state of Qatar confirms
the need to hold those perpetrating such
atrocities and war crimes and crimes
against humanity in Syria since the
beginning of this crisis to hold them
accountable before international justice
and legitimacy in here Qatar continues
to uphold its international
responsibilities along with the
international community it supports the
international independent mechanism to
assist in the investigation and the
prosecution of those responsible for
treating the most serious of crimes
perpetrated in Syria since March 2011 as
an element that would help arrive at a
political solution to the Syrian crisis
I thank you thank you and now give the
floor to the Foreign Minister of the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
Adel al-jubeir you have the floor
followed by Jordan thank you
Thank You Frith Rica for convening this
meeting and thank you Stefan for your
enormous efforts and for your most
recent briefing the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia believes in a political solution
based on Security Council resolution two
two five four that protects the
independence and territorial integrity
of Syria and that leads to the removal
of all foreign militias from Syria we
support the efforts of the UN Special
Envoy to convene the constitutional
committee as soon as possible and we
believe that all of us must work
together to encourage and pressure the
regime to can be to respond positively
to this we have worked on unifying the
Syrian opposition twice most recently in
bringing them together to support a
political process without preconditions
and this was done at the what is known
as the RIA 2 conference we have
contributed one hundred million dollars
in human hearing assistance to the
liberated to the areas liberated by the
international coalition from - we have
provided support for Refugees in
neighboring countries and we have
allowed more than 2 million Syrians to
enter Saudi Arabia of whom more than
300,000 still remain and none of them
lives in a tent the custodian of the Two
Holy Mosques decreed that they be
provided legal papers so they can have
access to jobs medical care and health
care and we will continue to do whatever
we can to support our Syrian brethren we
also look forward to working with the UN
Special Envoy and the international
community to extract Syria from describe
Meyer and to restore serious
independence and protect its territorial
integrity and I think it's very
important for all of us to be pushing in
the same direction in order to achieve
that objective thank you once again for
hosting this meeting thank you and I'll
give the floor to the foreign minister
of Jordan I'm on Safari
followed by Austria
thank you for Rica thank you all and I
just want to start by stressing how
important it was for us as a country
that hosts about 1.3 million citizens
almost 20% of the population how
important was to get the support that
you and the EU has provided without the
support from you and the rest of the
international community will not have
been able to do what we've been trying
very very hard to do for the Syrian
refugees which is to provide them with a
good shot at life dignified life and an
opportunity to grow and go to school and
get the proper medical health and our
partnership with the UN has also been
tremendous in enabling us to provide
humanitarian supply not just to refugees
in Jordan but also a cross-border and
that is something that we're very proud
of as well and we'll continue with our
commitment to do that that said however
I must warn that the refugees are still
there and their problems are still real
the second generation Syrians are now
second graders in Jordan those who are
10 years old and went to schools in
Jordan are now either to go to
university or become child labour would
with no opportunity to look for and in
Jordan no matter what we will continue
to provide a school to every child will
continue to provide a dignified life to
every young man or woman because we know
the cost of not doing that is going to
be a tremendous crime against those
people but also a tremendous threat to
our collective security because if we
provide Syrians with dignity with a shot
at education with a decent life they
will be the people who'll go back and
reconstruct Syria when the time is right
and if we do not they will be frustrated
young men and women and and this
frustration is despair as you all know
is the environment which every spoiler
would want to use to spread havoc
against all of us so it is important
that we remain resilient it is important
that we continue to remember that the
conflict is still there and our effort
to support those people
ar-ar-ar must the second thing is you
know it's almost a javo when we when we
meet here we all say what we come
prepared to say it is a crisis that has
to end we're all against military
solution we all know that a military
solution will not get us there
we all support a political solution but
the reality is very progress is being
made towards really galvanizing our
collective weight and ability and effort
and really sit and focus and say let us
in this conflict and when we say it is a
political solution we need to remember
that a political solution should be fair
first and foremost about the Syrian
people and about Syria this is what the
conflict is all about and unfortunately
in an all the sort of the crowdedness of
efforts and talk and and and Clair's it
seems that the Syrian people are really
down the agenda and everything that's
being discussed so yes we need a
political solution but the ultimate goal
of the political solution should be to
end the crisis in the suffering and the
killing and the marginalization and to
do that we need to be realistic as well
and see what is it that we can do and
what is that we know what we cannot do
we've lived with slogans for so long and
slogans resonate very very well but can
we implement those slogans and who is
the victim of raising slogans that all
of us know cannot be implemented it is
the Syrian people again so I think you
know there there is a need for a reality
check let's get together let's get
towards a political solution let's
identify what is it that we want - a
political solution and let's be
realistic and the resist sort of the the
charm of you know great moral statements
which we all would love to be able to
hold up to but if we cannot watch is
more moral or watch is what is more
immoral to allow the conflict to
continue with all the destruction and
killing that it's bringing to the Syrian
people or to say you know let's do what
we can and gradually move towards a
better situation which should be a
situation in which we preserve integrity
unity of Syria preserve the dignity of
the Syrian people restore their country
restore peace and allow the Syrian
people to
forward and collect the pieces and move
on together and I think that is the
question that we need to do and that
said a realistic step is to support
stefan de Mistura and his effort a
realistic step is to go to Geneva get
the constitutional committee convene and
make sure that Geneva is not a one-off
one on kind of exercise we come for a
week we talk then we go for three months
and in those three months more people
who have been killed more people who
have been displaced and we're back so I
think what we need to do if we all agree
there's no military solution let us just
go to do to the Geneva lock the door and
say this is the mandate this is what we
need to do and connectively put all our
efforts and resources to move forward to
a solution so the convening of the of
that committee is key as a practical
first step - as a practical solution
we've all mitigated crises that could
have deteriorated into disasters we've
seen what happened in the south a couple
of months ago Anna and I have to say it
was you know we worked with Russia and
we were able to produce reconciliation
agreement that saved tens of thousands
of lives we continued to work within the
framework of the small group with our
American allies with our European allies
and everybody else an arab arab brothers
to try on and come up with something and
we'll continue to do that but i think
what we need is clarity of objective
really realism and to make sure that we
all remember that the ultimate goal is
to save the Syrian and Syrian people to
immune them to the extent possible so
much into the damage that has been done
immune them from the struggle for
agendas and the interest of everybody
who's fighting everybody on Syria at the
expense of Syria and the expense of the
Syrian people that is that is something
that we have to say another point I'd
like to say as again as a country that
is suffering from 18.4% unemployment it
is in our interest to provide conditions
conducive for the voluntary return of
the Syrian people and therefore we
encourage the voluntary voluntary return
of the Syrian people but you know what
it's going to come down to this a father
a mother and three kids having dinner if
they can't afford it and they'll say do
we go back and the question will be will
my kids be safe will I be able to put
put foot put food on the table well I
have dignity if the answer is yes they
will go if the answer is no they will
not go and and the the answer to these
questions will come from a cousin a
relative a neighbor will pick up the
phone and say come back and is safe to
do that I think we need to again
differentiate between reconstruction and
stabilization we need to invest in
stabilization because whether you're a
kid growing under regime control or
under opposition control if you don't go
to school 15 years you are going to be a
lost generation whether we like it or
not so we have to provide schools it
doesn't matter where those kids are by
the end of the day the children the
reserve education we have to invest in
that we have to create environment that
would allow for those people to live in
dignity because we spoke we spoke on on
- - is not totally gone yes it lost its
made territorial control but - is still
there and if we do not address those
conditions - will thrive on ignorant
despair lack of sense of dignity and it
will come back so I think we need to
look at the broader picture again I want
to thank you so much for for this I
appreciate all you've done and I hope we
can continue to be partners in doing the
right thing humanitarian perspective and
political perspective thank you Thank
You Ayman I would now give the floor to
the Austrian foreign minister Karen
Nestle followed by Japan Lebanon and
Iraq Karen
federica mogherini thank you for having
convened that it was a very dear subject
to us at our council meeting in the ANA
end of August and I congratulate you and
your colleagues that you could make it
happen here today and thank you for this
very strong appearance of all the
colleagues from the EU and beyond I wish
to second what my colleague from the
Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan has said
it's all about reality check we
shouldn't get lost in semantics the new
catch word is stabilization we were
stuck with reconstruction we were stuck
with humanitarian assistance but it is
about what all what the Turanian
colleague has just stated and I don't
want to repeat on that I would simply
like also to state having worked and
lived in Syria for many years I simply I
am confident I'm even optimistic that
they will make it because it's the place
where the soap has come from our
civilization wouldn't be the one if
Aleppo hadn't provided with us with soap
it's the place who gave it we're
alphabet has come from and it's where
the first big novels were written and I
know that the civilization can find
comfort in history despite all the
hiccups that history can bring you with
but when you know that you're looking
back to a strongly stated civilization
that has given so much to humanity the
universities of Aleppo and Homs and and
Damascus they were the ones who brought
the first chapters of the Mediterranean
civilization which later on became the
European civilization so whether this
war is now ending or not it's Tea Leaf
reading for many of us we have heard
from Staffan de Mistura in 2017 that the
war was about to end
unfortunately in between we had other
fights as the u.s. colleague has said
maybe the war is not going to be and
it's so soon but we should also not be
stuck with that wars in our times don't
end in a fully-fledged way like the war
of 1945 and it
that was a totalitarian war that ended
because of expulsion by everybody
Syrians are exhausted those who are not
yet exhausted are the sponsors sometimes
behind the war here and there but I hope
that that we will see some sort of
Sevilla stabilization where people can
go back political perspective as Staffan
de Mistura has mentioned it in our
council meeting it's something this
cannot be assured but it's all about the
minimum services water and electricity
and if you have only one or two hours of
water a day or electricity you can make
it because you will then arrange your
day that's the way people in the Middle
East whether they I'm back that or in
Beirut or whether they are in Gaza they
have made it somehow to survive also
with a very limited time of electricity
and and water so I would like to to go
to what we from an Austrian perspective
would like to see happen in tandem with
all what has already been mentioned when
it comes to political solutions a new
chapter first there has to be a disposal
of the explosive remnants of war and
mine clearance rockets cluster munition
other war Alex they are there it has
already been minute mentioned by the
Russian delegate what the D mining is
done in the framework of it's an
initiative of refugee return two
essential points have not yet been
addressed namely Syria has not signed so
far the Ottawa Convention on the
prohibition of anti-personnel mines and
I think this would be a good moment to
go that also in order to to to accede to
the conventions both on classic
Convention on Cluster Munitions
and on landmines second we as the
European Union we are committed to
strengthening what I just mentioned
beforehand this tremendous resilience of
the Syrian population that we should go
as far as possible in our humanitarian
assistance or called stabilization
without changing our general position on
reconstruction and here what would not
be better than instead of concentrating
on war
to delivery we caught we repair the
water distribution system this has been
done by courageous civilians here and
there by engineers who do it despite
everything by those who remained but it
require in my view the help on the
ground and the reforms should go hand in
hand and water distribution as to many
other pressing needs that the Syrians
face in order to live and to survive and
not to survive some harbours to survive
in dignity that can be done and I hope
that in our meeting we can contribute as
the previous speakers in particular from
the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan and many
others have addressed reality check and
not hiding behind mantras thank you
thank you Karina now give the floor to
the Foreign Minister of Japan taro kono
followed by Lebanon let me begin by
expressing my deep concern over the
possibility of a large-scale military
conflict in Italy province I am also
concerned about potential use of
chemical weapons in Italy which will
never be tolerated under any
circumstances
I appreciate the ongoing international
effort to avoid a humanitarian disaster
I strongly support and will actively
cooperate with the effort of mr. de
Mistura un special envoy for Syria
including the establishment of the
constitutional committee it is important
that the advancement of the political
process
lead to an environment where Syrian
refugees in Europe and neighboring
countries and internal internally
displaced people are able to return to
their homes voluntarily safely and
peacefully when the political process is
advanced Japan is ready to contribute to
the risk construction of Syria as a
responsible member of the international
community neighboring countries such as
Jordan and Lebanon also need to be
assisted for the regional stability
Japan's assistance to Syria and
neighboring countries has reached over
2.2 billion
dollars since 2012 we are committed to
delivering humanitarian assistance to
all Syrians facing difficulties no
matter who controlled the area we also
continue to provide assistance to Easton
Goethe South Syria and Northwest Syria
where needs of the humanitarian
assistance are high we will also provide
assistance for displaced people from it
Lib to care for those who are most
vulnerable in this conflict
Japan will devote even greater resources
to women in health care I am pleased to
announce that Japan has recently
dedicated approximately 10 million u.s.
dollars for medical services for Syrian
citizens and internally displaced people
I hope the next conference will take
place in a more positive environment
Japan remains firmly committed to
playing a leading role in both the
humanitarian and political spheres in
international efforts to solve the
Syrian crisis thank you very much thank
you very much taro I now give the floor
to the foreign minister of Lebanon Abram
Basile furrowed by ROK well I think that
the situation has changed on the ground
in Syria everybody admits this but I
think that we should act accordingly
we are still neglecting this fact and
trying to link the reconstruction of
Syria and the return of the refugees to
Syria with the political solution is an
attempt that allow me to tell you will
fail and will appear to be useless later
on and why I'm saying this because
thinking that having a leverage using
these two issues in order to have a
political solution will appear bit by
bit
that it will not be very useful a
political solution in Syria will be
reached
and Syria cannot live without a new
constitution we are a neighboring
country who suffered from a civil war
and we were not able to start our life
again without having what we call the
tithe agreement which is our
constitution and Syria there has to be
nobody can ignore this nor the regime
nor the opposition they will have to
reach or life will be unbearable in
Syria and fight will keep on going no no
matter what but linking these two issues
let me let me talk about the
reconstruction first of course it is a
sovereign decision by any country to
decide not to participate in a country
like Syria to finance any Reconstruction
operation but this will happen and let
me tell you that this is happening now
you will find countries willing to
participate and they are showing this
and you will have the private sector
from your countries willing to
participate and they will do so this for
Lebanon is in our interest because
Lebanon can be applied platform for
their construction of Syria after that
we paid at least direct cost of 20
billion dollars on our economy our
unemployment rate has moved from 9
percent to 20 percent and four years so
Lebanon will take advantage of this one
once it happens but this is not our main
concern you know our main concern is on
the refugees and here again we are using
the same rhetoric of the voluntary
return of the sea of the Syrians and
nobody I believe not in Lebanon at least
is talking ever about a forced return of
the refugees but we have to take this
issue not as the whole we have to divide
it first there are the refugees who are
in our host countries for economic
reasons and they are the majority and
this is shown I and I think you can
check it anyway possible second you have
the political refugees and they are the
minority very little of them and you
have the security refugees these are
three categories and on another hand you
have to treat them with those who are
coming originally from safe regions now
or not who have their houses demolished
or not who have any kind of obstacles
not allowing them to return whether it
is the military service whether it is
their right to property or or whatever
so here dealing with them in categories
will allow them to have a gradual return
that will take a long time but that will
allow a country of Lebanon to to live
again telling us that we will link this
to a political solution which which is
indefinite and time how can we know here
we have Cypriot friend who had this
crisis since 1974 and until now they are
our neighboring country they didn't come
up with a political solution and we have
a worse case which is that of the
Palestinians after 70 years there is no
political solutions and we are trying to
shut down UNRWA now by telling the
Palestinians that you stay where you are
and you have no hope to return home so
for us linking this to a political
solution means that you are telling the
Syrians you stay in Lebanon you stay in
Jordan you stay in Turkey the more time
passes the more they will be integrated
and our society is something that we
cannot we cannot bear at all so what I
would like to suggest and we had
fruitful conversation lately with HCR
and I think that moving first away from
trying to discourage the Syrians from
returning back home because the
financing of their stay and Lebanon for
example is something that is hindering
their return we go to them we ask them
you wanna go back they say yes why you
are not going back they tell you we are
paid for nutrition for shelter for
education for health why should we go
back if you provide this in Syria
definitely we choose to go back so let's
think of ways and find a way operating
mode you know a mechanism of allowing
the Syrians once they have all the
needed conditions for their return to
think how we can really finance this
return because paying for them where
they are is something that will never
end
it is from the taxpayers that is really
sometimes directed to people who are not
in a really needy situation so let's
categorize them and see how we pay for
those who cannot really return now you
are paying for people who can really
return to safe areas they have no
political problems their houses are safe
their life is not jeopardized they have
no reason not to return their only
reason they are paid to stay where they
are so dividing the problem like this I
think will allow us to having a gradual
solution of the problem and this will
not I believe in any way encourage the
Syrians not to dialogue and to really
work for for a political solution
holding this card will not really
accelerate the political solution I hope
that there will be an understanding of
our situation yesterday president Trump
himself said that the best thing for the
migrants is to stay at home because they
will make their country great again so I
I believe everybody will realize sooner
or later that this is the only solution
or al
as Lebanon is suffering everybody will
be suffering maybe in a smaller scale
and at a later stage but you know how
much Europe will be suffering from the
thank you thank you with this principle
New York would have missed some great
mayors that are in Italian origin but
that's another story
let me give now the floor to the Iraqi
foreign minister followed by Algeria mr.
Asif re you have the floor Malaya
microphone please microphone to Iraq God
peace be upon you all allow me at the
outset to thank the European Union and
the United Nations for organizing this
event in order to provide support to the
future of Syria and the region we would
like to thank madam mogherini for her
initiative and we would also like to
thank mr. de Mistura the international
representative for Syria to support the
peace process led by the United Nations
we meet yet once again to discuss a very
sensitive matter
the current unacceptable situation of
the Syrian people despite the decrease
of the military activities in the
southern western part of Syria because
the government was able to recover the
territories that used to be controlled
by armed conflicts and has been able to
restore its sovereignty over these
regions here we would like to call upon
all parties to respect their commitments
under international law and humanitarian
law - to guarantee the safety of
civilians we categorically reject all
acts of terror we believe that these are
criminal acts that cannot be justified
wherever and whoever committed them and
we believe that any effort that our
adopt that is adopted within resolution
24:01 of 2018
that calls for combating the terror
groups defined by the Security Council
to be able to separate them from
civilians and we would like also to look
into the respect of international law
and protecting civilians my country
welcomes the agreement that was reached
between Syria and Turkey to establish a
demilitarized zone in the governor of
Eid Lib the Sochi agreement is a result
of concentrated diplomatic efforts in
Ankara and Damascus which was followed
by a summit among Iran Russia and Turkey
in Tehran the agreement was based on the
spirit of the Astana process and the
approach to establish de-escalation
zones in order to end the tension and
limit the possibility of injuring
civilians while combating terrorism the
Russian turkey agreement is also a step
in the right direction and is compatible
with the efforts by Iran Russia and
Turkey to cooperate in order to to
combat all terrorists while taking
humanitarian considerations into account
eight years have passed with with the
military solution what was the result
more bloodshed more displacement more
instability and negative impacts on the
Syrian society it also threatened the
safety of neighboring countries ending
terrorism and violence would be one of
the most important tenets of our foreign
policy combating terrorism requires a
comprehensive approach that takes into
account all the dimensions of this
heinous phenomenon we would like to
stress yet once again the the need to
respect Syria's independence and
territorial integrity in a way that
would allow Syria to control other parts
of its territories which is its natural
right like any other statement
[Music]
chairperson the international community
must welcome the agreement and
contribute positively in its
implementation we hope that this
agreement will will will help in ending
the the tragedy of the Syrian people and
to clear the country from terrorist
elements while taking into account
humanitarian considerations the return
of displaced persons will will
contribute to the ceasefire national
dialogue and expedite the reconciliation
process it's very important to allow
Syrians to embark on a syrian-led
political process the right to
self-determination and to the
determination of the the right to the
determination of the future of Syria
should be given to Syrians alone we need
to cooperate so that a committee at
constitutional committee should be
established Syria is going through and
in a very critical stage the
international community must stop must
and sent by sand with Syria and the
international community helped Iraq at
some point and we hope that it will do
the same for Syria thank you madam
chairperson thank you very much I now
give the floor to the Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Algeria should Canada
relate
first of all I would like to fulfill a
pleasant duty that is incumbent upon me
as I was saying I would like to equip
myself with a pleasant duty of thanking
you for having taken this initiative as
well as all the other organizers which
has allowed us to address this audience
to share some reflections on the Syrian
crisis but I'm over centuries sir was an
example
of living together against which no
foreign occupation was able to overcome
today there it has pulled all of its
people and all of its religious groups
to name
unfortunately this togetherness has
exploded and been torn about who we see
the most blood bloody images of
terrorism I would like to reiterate in
on this in this respect that under all
circumstances and this applies to Syria
the destabilizing factors lead to a
deviation of the peace processes and
undermine the peaceful solutions through
inclusive dialogue and national
reconciliation
I must underscore that the Syrian people
also have the right as all other peoples
in the world due to the respect of their
sovereign well to freely decide their
just a name
therefore it is fundamental that Syrians
should own the definitive and lasting
solution to this crisis as my common
comrade from Iraq has said by placing
the supreme interest of the country
above all other concerns collectively
responding to the legitimate desires of
this people to leave and to live in
peace and security it is in this regard
that Algeria has provided its assistance
to the UN and to the Istana process to
lead to a peaceful process leading to a
constructive dialogue between all the
different serene interlocutors along
these lines I would like to reaffirm the
support of the Algerians to the Syrian
people in its fight against terrorism in
order to hold on to its stability and
its and the security of Syria the Union
and the cohesion of its people we must
or the fact that the living situations
and the weakening of the central
authorities in certain countries have
provided terrorists with an opportunity
to occupy territories to submit the
civilian populations to barbarianism to
control the reserve resources to
intensify and widen the scope of the
criminal actions as such fighting
against terrorism was always a threat
that no country has ever been completely
protected against and it remains a
challenge that should concern the entire
international community our efforts
ladies and gentlemen must be part of a
collective undertaking to assist and
help Syria in its quest for stability
and the respect of its sovereignty
sovereignty and obviously to oversee the
return of the refugees to their own
country thank you for your attention
Chrystia Freeland Paris a reckless Sigma
monitor Rica merci d'avoir convocation
Fei Union ocmi vemos en envoy SPC alone
Sara Delano Stefan de Mistura ka pila
may poor Santa by a Schaffner since the
beginning of the war the Assad regime
has committed grave violations of
international law it has regularly
bombed and indiscriminately targeted
civilians creating a massive refugee
crisis with international repercussions
worst of all it has used chemical
weapons against its own people
all of these heinous acts have been
enabled by Assad supporters Russia and
Iran they share moral responsibility for
them as we speak
the people of a Lib are living in fear
of a large-scale escalation of attacks
from forces loyal to Assad we pray for
the sake of those who live there that
the deal reached last week will hold and
it is an important achievement but we
mustn't be complacent
and assume that it will in looking ahead
to Syria's future I want to emphasize
the importance of including Syrian women
in the peacemaking process including the
constitutional process women's voices
are essential in building a lasting
peace when faced with a situation as
dire as serious it is easy for those
affected and for us the international
community to fear that we are helpless
to fix it Canada
like so many countries here has tried in
small ways to make a difference
since our government came to office my
country has welcomed more than 50,000
Syrian refugees and I do even as I
mention that I do want to say that that
pales in comparison with the work of
Jordan Lebanon and Turkey in providing a
home for Syrian refugees and we salute
that work and I would really like to
acknowledge that this is an
international issue and we will continue
to support you in doing that work inside
Syria as well there are countless people
who are bravely working to make a
difference I cannot think of any group
more courageous in this efforts than the
white helmets their stated mission is to
save the greatest number of lives in the
shortest possible time and to minimize
further injury to people and damage to
property that makes them heroes it has
also made them targets I'd like to take
this opportunity here to reject in the
strongest possible terms the smears we
have heard today about the white helmets
oh so may dilute an epoxy long ve le
ministre Mazda del mangia my Newsom
hound you can't canoe packaging we
realized that we share many
preoccupations concerning the white
helmets Jeremy Hunt Lenovo
mrs. ldiot many but shares our concerns
so in collaboration with the Netherlands
and Sweden and with the vital assistance
of Jordan Israel in the United States we
have sent 400 courageous white helmets
along with her families providing them
with asylum Canadian journalist wrote
the following saying the white helmets
would be exemplary Canadians and I am
absolutely in agreement with us these
are very few people to do with the
tragedy of Syria but it is better to
light a single candle than to remain in
obscurity this is what we have under
Kate undertaken congratulation although
I do want especially today after we've
heard to underscore our very strong
support and admiration for the work of
the white helmets but I do tell this
story to demonstrate that working
together it is possible for us to act on
our values and to make a difference
however small we have to harness this
energy as we continue the difficult work
of negotiating an enduring political
solution to the Syrian crisis and
holding those responsible for atrocious
and barbaric acts to account we must
remain firm and steadfast in our resolve
to do what is right and ultimately to
help the people of Syria to win the
peace and justice that they deserve and
I am very glad that Stephan de Mistura
has returned so I can directly thank him
for his extremely hard indefatigable and
courageous work on this issue thanks
everyone
Thank You vinegar now we are going to
the humanitarian part of our event
distinguished members of the panel dear
colleagues dear friends once again thank
you for being here today eight years
after the beginning of the conflict as
stefan de Mistura already insisted on
this Syria remains allow me to say this
an open humanitarian wound each new
escalation triggers tremendous
humanitarian needs and human suffering
the war as we already admitted is far
from over
and a political solution is more urgent
than ever I say I recognize all of us we
agree on this the european union remains
concerns about the situation in italy
following the recent agreement between
Turkey and Russia and Federica
and Stefan already supported this
agreement then is this fact to create a
demilitarized buffer we must ensure the
protection of the nearly three million
civilians living in the province and
their unbeaten access to humanitarian
assistance regardless of what happens
protection of civilians must be central
to respond to needs we have updated our
contingency plan and strengthened our
preparedness to act swiftly and meet the
needs of affected population in the
region but our efforts will be wasted
without humanitarian access most
importantly we must never give up on
those thinking the political solution
protection of civilians is our biggest
humanitarian challenge in our patterns I
wish matter happens here they will
describe with clear words and sentences
about the situation on the ground
I would like to say a few words about
the situation in Syria the millions of
civilians in hard-to-reach areas the
civilian infrastructure schools hospital
which is started on a regular basis the
millions of internally displaced and
their hosts as I said access is our peak
inshaallah for eight workers operating
syria unfortunately human dairy workers
and assets are constantly under attack
this is the hard reality on the ground
region in syria changed hands but
humanitarian needs remain the same I
want to be clear on this we cannot
afford a humanitarian vacuum in the
country all parties to the conflict must
respect international humanitarian law
they must protect civilians and civilian
infrastructure
this is images just already Staffan de
Mistura / decent all of us and of course
allow aid workers to do their job in
security and in safety dear colleagues
production our number one challenge not
only in Syria but across the region this
is particularly true in countries host
is more than five and half million
Syrian refugees Turkey Lebanon Jordan
Iraq in Egypt they are the pillars of
the humanitarian response to the
conflict in Syria without an inclusive
viable political solution displacement
and seven will continue our top
priorities to cover the pressing needs
of 13 million affected people in Syria
we must continue delivering with
humanity impartiality neutrality and
independence this is our humanitarian
principle it is vital that we will all
remain at the forefront of the
humanitarian response in Syria in the
wider region and it is essential that we
all stay on the track of the process
conference in 2017 and 2019 honoring our
humid area commitments and translating
our promises into real
greed solidarity so desperately needed
by millions of innocent insane series
then of course as with the regularity
announced we will continue our efforts
in the next summit in next year of
course our hope is to see political
solution until this date but until then
we have to continue especially our
humanitarian efforts in order to reduce
the suffering of these people in
sincerely thank you so much and now
thank you very much indeed Federico
Christo's I'm I'm conscious that time is
our enemy in this discussion we don't
have much longer and Christos has done a
fantastic job in setting out the overall
humanitarian context and we update all
the Member States every month on that
through the sector generals report and
through the briefing I do to the
Security Council so I just like to make
three key points given the limited time
available firstly while there's the
situation across much of Syria is common
now than it was I'm certainly at the
beginning of this year or the peak of
the fighting there are some very real
remaining risks last week did offer
potential good news for those three
million civilians in Italy but let's
remember that most of those people are
people displaced from other parts of the
country a million of them are children
and those civilians outnumber fighters
by an estimated 100 to one
so the agreement reached between as a
result of work by Turkey and Russia is
an extremely important agreement but the
central issue is whether it's going to
be fully implemented and whether the
agreement last not just for a few weeks
but permanently because it needs to be a
permanent agreement if that catastrophe
we've been warning off in Italy is to be
a genuine genuinely avoided and we're
probably ways to provide genuine hope
for those those people so everything has
to be done to make the make sure the
agreement is fully implemented and the
risks are enormous and as staff earnest
said terrorism needs to be addressed in
a way which is consistent with
international humanitarian law civilians
have to be respected and protected
principled humanitarian action must be
facilitated in humanitarian access
through the most direct routes including
the cross-border operations must be
sustained
secondly those principles also apply in
other parts of the country and I want to
say a word about rook ban close to the
Syria and Jordanian border whether the
humanitarian situation has deteriorated
significantly over the last month with
reports of deaths and malnutrition and
increased insecurity and extremely
limited supplies of basic goods the last
un food delivery to the camp from the
Jordanian side of the berm took place
nearly nine months ago community leaders
are now reporting that families are
surviving on one meal every two days and
we've had long-running discussions about
providing relief assistance to those
communities by convoys from Damascus and
it's now urgent that those discussions
are concluded successfully and rapidly
so that help can reach those people
otherwise we will have a we will have a
very dramatic situation the third point
I want to make is that in face of the
enormous challenges humanitarian
organizations do continue to assist
millions of people both inside Syria and
in neighboring countries every month and
that is only possible because of the
generosity of international donors who
provided more than eight and a half
billion dollars for un coordinated
humanitarian activities inside Syria
since 2012 it is critical that
limitations imposed on our ability to
independently assess needs and to
deliver aid to the most vulnerable are
lifted so that we can ensure principled
and accountable aid operations those
limitations are the fundamental
constraints at the moment on resource
mobilization lifting them would help
restore donor confidence and assurance
and potential donors that help is
genuinely targeted in a neutral
impartial way on the people in in
greatest need and indeed that that hell
reaches those same people thank you very
much
and because the time is really limited I
now give the floor for another briefing
by filippo grandi UN High Commissioner
for Refugees thank you
I guess this meeting was supposed to be
us briefing you and then you comment him
but since everybody has commented
already on refugees let me comment back
to you and two points only in the
interest of time first just to make
clear UNHCR's position our position
recognizes that refugees have the
fundamental human right to return in
safety and dignity at the time of their
own choosing and we support all action
that contributes to the full exercise of
that right so the free and informed
decision of Syrians to return remains
from the point of your principles key
and fundamentally this is what Minister
Safari the Aiman said earlier about the
process of decision making by refugees
themselves and this is by the way
consistent with our position on
voluntary return in any situation of
Refuge now what refugees tell us in the
countries of asylum is that there are
certain concerns that they have they
belong to three areas one is security
the other one is material needs and the
third one is a complex set of legal and
administrative issues ranging from
property issues to a fear of lengthy
conscription and fighting to
documentation to retribution and so
forth and we will continue to work you
know we are not about putting conditions
we will continue to work with all of you
to address this obstacle so that
voluntary Ritter so that that choice
that people have to make becomes becomes
possible and for those who do make the
decision to return there are not many
but there have been some and many more
among the internally displaced people we
will have to provide humanitarian
assistance and assistance to the initial
reintegration just a few more words to
echo all those that have thanked once
again the host countries Lebanon Jordan
Turkey Iraq and Egypt and other
countries we should not forget that this
is still the largest refugee population
in the world 5.6 million people and I
think that we should not say thank you
to the host country and take it for
granted all the time that thank-you has
to be substantive not formal and I do
thank donors through the only the
refugee appeals of the UN we have
mobilized over the many years
unfortunately thirteen billion dollars
unfortunately it is not enough this year
the appeal is only 41 percent funded and
we are towards the end of the year
eighty percent in average of the
refugees live below the poverty line 35
percent of the refugee children are
still out of school and this exposes
them to exploitation early marriage and
all form of discrimination and it has a
very heavy impact on host country so the
commitments made first in London in 2016
and reiterated in Brussels in other
plane in other conferences must be
maintained not only through humanitarian
assistance but medium and longer-term
assistant and finally may I also make an
appeal to all countries that have
resettlement programs for Syrian
refugees to maintain those programs
because there is small but significant
gesture of solidarity with countries
hosting refugees let me just conclude by
thanking Federica and Christos for
hosting us here and welcoming very much
the information that we received that
they will be
a conference in Brussels in which I hope
we will already be at the stage of the
political process where we can move
forward with the aid discussion to new
areas thank you
Thank You Philippa for your clear
briefing a clear message now
administrator of UNDP mr. Steiner for
another PC Thank You crystal Thank You
Federico excellencies ladies and
gentlemen together with Mark and Filippo
I joined this morning's discussion fully
conscious of many fine lines many
timelines many red lines that have been
articulated in the response of the
international community in the context
of developments within and also around
Syria I want to also commend and thank
our colleague the special envoy Staffan
de Mistura for promoting the peace talks
under the UN Security Council resolution
as Mark and Filippo have highlighted the
current plight of Syrians requires a
sustained effort both on the
humanitarian and resilience fronts
inside Syria as well as in neighboring
countries the United Nations Development
Program is committed to complement the
important work of our humanitarian
colleagues by the nature of our mandate
in to help strengthen local level
community resilience within the
framework of the humanitarian response
plan throughout our work UNDP adheres to
and is aligned with the principle
approach led by the UN Secretary General
on Syria and focuses on localized
conflict sensitive people center
activities in two key areas
rehabilitation local services and
support emergency livelihoods despite
the many challenges and thanks to the
support of our generous donors that both
of my colleagues have already referred
to we have so far this year reached over
2.1 million people as beneficiaries
overall our activities aim at
reinforcing the sustainability of
life-saving humanitarian interventions
by building resilience of individuals
and communities and enhancing their
ability to take part in recovery once
this process starts
it is important to remember that Syria
is made up of 17 million Syrians that
continue to struggle to find peace and
livelihoods and were according to our
United Nations assessment 69% 69 percent
of the population have fallen into
extreme poverty they deserve our
undivided attention and support and
supporting these communities is also key
to planning for the expected return of
refugees and the more immediate
challenge of IDP returns I also want to
echo with great admiration my colleagues
expression of the gratitude that we feel
towards the countries of the region in
particular Jordan Lebanon and Turkey as
well as Iraq and Egypt the regional
refugee and resilience plan the so
called 3rp call led by UNDP and UNHCR
continues to be a cornerstone of
international support to assist these
countries without going into details all
three representatives have this morning
alluded to the enormous challenges they
face and enormous pressures under which
the international support is currently
being deployed this this year the total
3rp appeal amounted to 5.6 billion
dollars with 41 percent of the
interagency asked dedicated to
resilience so far only 42 percent of the
three RPS appeal has been funded with
the resilience component chronically
underfunded I appeal to all partners to
lend their support through the voices
the examples and the pressures that are
being felt by the countries who have
spoken here this morning meanwhile and
crystals are in with us it is also
critical that efforts aimed at
responding to the refugee crisis are
closely tied to actions aimed at
addressing wider developmental
challenges Lebanon and the international
community have paved the way for this
approach with a seeder conference a
similar event is being planned in Jordan
in the coming months
UNDP stands ready to support these
efforts in conclusion and despite the
many and significant challenges inherent
to the Syria crisis I am grateful that
our collaboration has led to the
practical implementation of the
humanitarian development Nexus so often
invoked constantly power particularly of
Marx and my endeavors in leading a UN
system that is joined up
but not naive nor blind to the complex
political territory in which we move and
I try to live up to the commitment of
the United Nations thank you for your
contribution not only through this
briefing but for your organization on
the ground now president of ICRC mr.
Peter Maurer dear colleagues as the
Syrian conflict moves into a protracted
situation with fewer or less visible
front lines we hope that some people
will have the chance to start rebuilding
their lives our humanitarian action will
support them on both sides of the
current or former frontlines
you will strive for sustainable
humanitarian impact to build on people's
industriousness and the strength in
their capacity to overcome adversity
well the international community will
have to answer difficult question and we
have heard it this morning about the
long-term reconstruction of Syria and
the political conditions humanitarian
still needs to respond to people's needs
and their wish to live with dignity they
cannot wait for political consensus we
will work to support people in
rebuilding their houses their basic
infrastructures to find jobs and
economic opportunities to searching for
missing relatives and reminding the
authorities of the obligations towards
their own citizens in particular we will
have to address the humanitarian
consequences of some of the most
devastating impacts of urban warfare in
Syria just as we do and work in Mosul in
sudah or in Gaza our action will not be
motivated by political considerations
but based on independent and impartial
assessments of the humanitarian needs of
individuals and communities importantly
humanitarian action for people in Syria
should not be held hostage to
controversies about return the legal
situation is clear people who have been
forcefully displaced have a right to
return in safety and dignity they also
have a right not to be returned to
situations where the rights are at risk
humanitarian action can con
to help return IDPs and refugees to
recover their lives just as it seeks to
support those who have stayed without
however being used as a fig leaf to
return people forcefully we cannot
forget that the conditions for IDPs and
refugees to return to not merely depend
on repaired water systems but on safety
and respects for their rights dear
colleagues humanity is not measured by
the tons of relief items shaped and
distributed but by the recovery of
people in need by the recovery of
grieving families of missing persons
those left detained children who have
never known a life without war the
children families of foreign fighters
recently visited by our teams also
cannot be forgotten and deserve humanity
children need to have access to
education and psychological support they
need to have a future we will continue
to seek access to all detainees and we
are setting ourselves up to help
authorities tackle the daunting caseload
of missing persons which will continue
to haunt the region for decades to come
this lies at the heart of our mandate
given to us by the international
community
we'll continue to engage with all
parties to the conflict to try to build
a constructive dialogue about respect
for international humanitarian law and
the protection of the civilian
population I thank you thank you very
much Peter now the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Hungary and following Norway
thank you for the floor thank you for
the opportunity I would like to touch
upon an aspect of this crisis which
aspect has been addressed barely and
unacceptably barely which is the destiny
of the Christian communities living or
used to be living in Syria we barely
speak about them although we speak a lot
about diversity multiculturalism the
colorfulness of this region but we
hardly speak about the Christians this
portrays a approach which kind of says
or suggest as if Christian of phobia
would be the last acceptable form of
discrimination which we definitely find
unacceptable and we reject that if we
take into consideration the fact that
four out of all five persons on the
globe who are tortured or killed because
of his or her ly belief are Christians
we have to take this issue seriously
into consideration and in the Middle
East including in Syria there is a real
threat that the Christian communities
will be eliminated and I'm speaking
about those Christian communities who
have been living in the neighborhood not
only for centuries but for a millennium
already their houses are torn down the
schools are closed churches are torn
down hospitals cannot operate since I'm
representing a Christian country we feel
a responsibility to protect these
Christian communities in our government
your excellency mr. commissioner we have
established a separate state Secretariat
which has the only only obligation to
monitor the situation and the destiny of
the Christian communities worldwide who
are in need we have allocated and spent
15 million euros on reconstructing the
torn down houses of the Christian
families to rebuild their churches to
strengthen
their communities and to rebuild their
schools
we have donated that almost two and a
half million dollars to the Greek
Catholic Archdiocese of Aleppo to carry
out their projects to rebuild the houses
of those Christian families who can
return to their homes we have been
supporting the humanitarian actions of
the Syrian Orthodox Church to be able to
take care of the Christian refugees mr.
commissioner dear colleagues I think we
have to make it sure that we do our we
make our best in order to make it
possible for the Christian communities
which had to leave their homes to be
able to return sometimes we have the
experience that even on the deliberated
areas it's impossible for them to return
because of legal and physical reasons I
think UN should guarantee and here
European Union should play a role
I think UN should guarantee a legal and
physical security for these families who
were forced to leave their homes to able
to be able to return mr. Commissioner we
Hungarians are ready to take part in
this endeavor in order to make it
possible for the Christian communities
to continue their lives in Syria and in
the Middle East where they have been
living for not only centuries but for a
millennia and from where they were
forced to live thank you very much now
the representatives of the civil society
organization mr. Hosni Alberta
thank you so much for your presence here
it's very important for us to hear your
voice and to see your opinions
especially because you can represent the
situation on the ground thank you so
much
okay Thank You commissioner good morning
to the dignitaries I guess the biggest
thing I've been asked to come forward
today and speak to you on behalf of the
NGOs is to keep it positive because at
the topic that is very troubling as NGOs
working in Syria and the region we wish
to thank the EU for the opportunity to
address the UN member-states today I
come to you as been cited earlier from
the heart of civilization and the
epicentre of religions tolerance and
coexistence I come to you from Syria I
may be one of the few from Syria
representing the voices of millions of
my fellow citizens who lives have been
shattered and for many words can't
describe their pain no words of their
expressed outrage no words can express
their despair but we're hopeful and
we're resilient as it's been stated
earlier I believe madam Murray indicated
earlier this morning that we should talk
to Syrians versus talk about Syrians and
I thank her and the European Union to
allow us the space today one ask I was
requested to speak from the heart as I
look in the room a lot of professionals
a lot of degrees a lot of smarts I'm
just a humble young man from the city of
Hama for that allow me to speak to the
heart for all the declarations and the
resolutions that are passed in the last
seven years the military approach this
conflict endures millions of Syrians are
deprived of their rights and remain in
need of critical life-saving
humanitarian assistance but more
importantly dignity has been lost
let me raise my voice and ask to the
parties to this conflict and member
states with influence over these parties
whether in astana Geneva or through the
UN Security Council
you have committed to improving the
humanitarian access and relief can we
ask you to respect and enforce those
pressures can we expect you to take
concrete steps to improve compliance
with the International Unitarian law and
end impunity for the violators equally
stop the attacks on schools and
hospitals protect our colleagues on the
ground too many have died my own
organization have suffered often
targeted precisely because of the work
they do and they should not be
criminalized to the sole basis of
humanitarian service today I take this
podium and salute their sacrifices and
honor their memories
the second mandate of my speech was to
keep it positive as I indicated earlier
despite the member state differences you
have already agreed to these commitments
now we count on you to translate your
intentions into facts on the ground I
think to attribute to what stated
earlier by this special envoy de Mistura
the recent agreement in Italy could
prove to be a turning point at the very
least it provides a reprieve for the
children and their families millions of
whom have been living in fear of the
major eminent military offensive but we
must build on this diplomatic progress
to agree a permanent ceasefire hood now
that spares people in Italy and across
Syria for further violence and suffering
and displacement
millions also continue to need our
support and assistance in neighboring
countries let us not forget that today
conditions for those safe voluntary and
dignified return of refugees remain
elusive and are unlikely to be met in
the near future for variety of reasons
no one should be forced to return any
organize large-scale repetition of
refugees from neighboring countries now
would risk being unsustainable and
creating yet more internal displaced
people as well as refugee flows backed
into host countries and onwards to
Europe and elsewhere I think the
international community must step up and
continue its support to the host
governments in the region the UN and the
civil society to deliver a response to
refugees and host communities that could
be sustainable while those in need
continue to require our help as well as
mitigate tensions to do this effectively
commissioner we count on your support on
a multi-year donor funding is part of
the essential success in order to
improve the quality of asylum in host
countries the important policy
commitment made at the Brussels to
conference earlier this year require
dogged follow-up it must be worked
finally
Syrians across the region have a little
faith left in the international system
designed to protect them and support
Syrian deserve to have their dignity
back we must not let them down
thank you very much commissioner thank
you so much you are called revolution in
your organization but unfortunately I
have this privilege to stop this event
this excellent exchange of youth because
for the next meeting here and sorry but
as you know as always in this event the
time always is limited and due to
shortage of time the event secretary
will be collecting your statements for
posting or the events internal side
thank you so much again for this
excellent exchange of views and we will
see again in Brussels next year maybe in
a completely different circumstances
thank you so much
[Applause]